саймон і важкий барабан наріжте можна
буду покрутить і рахіль крути відкрив пишу
експозицію музою контур культурного
майстерності нового тисячоліття відьмарі
інші види є
на віч через давні теракти в
брюсселі зі мною smd за раз вони так я
вкрай ш можна вич уват і шкода сюди ти
їх шляхів алея думаю значного жили віші
у серці ви провід і вигляд буду вати і
запустить і наш музей і вино з важливими лише
і
і для нас і для зусилля громади важливо
files in free квентин розчину не музей
Узі брав і а 600 тисяч євро ми ж вся
сума дібровин не в низькій для porsche та
виставкою прибрав і різанини видай з у
приватної майстерності скажімо а вісь мурал
нью-йоркську художницю моєї хайек та і
малюнки займають силу залу щоб дражнити
іца йому за і виду цих менших белль 6
експонаті у створі у тебе прямо на місці
вінів біс
а this week they do багатого з і
художники просіяти в публічних місцях
наприклад просто на висновку теж у
культурних центрах та музеях з них рубає
машина травня
incity вже не але заебло що у всіх будемо
чи колише бровар не в man in baku
районі кипить я брюссельських на подіум
називають оси рідко джихадизм а в Європі
рафаель крус одягаєте йогою нитку від
його зміни іміджу району тут гол ми
нашого музею забутий позитивні вниз
виявиться міцели і громади і
заміни ти стала не думав нбкр збоку
прибульців так і ти їх теж вага замажемо
і нашій столиці гресів образливо ти людей
до протестуючи ти ширше new терору ембід
нам це особливо у районі мальбек